je suis parissima je suis chaparac salé
je m'appelle Aurélie trotange depuis
1979 le régime islamique est un régime
très violent totalitaire qui réprime
toutes les libertés du peuple iranien
avec la mort de Marsa Amini le peuple
iranien s'est réveillé c'est à ce
moment-là qu'une révolte forte est née
en Iran le régime pour exercer sa main
mise sur le peuple il a déjà annilé une
moitié du peuple c'est-à-dire les femmes
il faut savoir qu'en Iran les femmes
n'ont pas le droit de faire du vélo de
la bicyclette elles ne peuvent pas
divorcer si elles le souhaitent ça doit
être soumis à l'autorisation de leur
mari elles ne peuvent pas non plus
danser chanter exprimer leur liberté
dans la rue si elles veulent aller à
l'hôtel elles doivent demander
l'autorisation de leur mari que
manifester aujourd'hui en Iran est un
crime tous les manifestants risquent la
peine de mort les bassidi choisissent
dans les manifestations les plus jolies
femmes qui les emmènent qu' les violent
et qu' les visent dans les yeux ou dans
le vagin pour les réduire au silence le
régime vit ces dernières heures pour le
pousser à bout et se débarrasser c'est
lui on a besoin d'un coup de pouce de
l'extérieur aujourd'hui le régime est
très riche contrairement au peuple qui
est très pauvre et il faut absolument
l'isoler diplomatiquement et
financièrement ce qui suppose d'inscrire
les Gardiens de la Révolution et tous
les membres importants de ce régime sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
l'association famemazadi est une
association que nous avons monté avec
neuf autres femmes franco-iraniennes qui
viennent de milieux divers et variés on
a commencé à mettre en place des actions
de plus en plus fortes on a commencé
avec une vidéo qui s'appelle alô le
monde qui a été vue à plus de 10
millions de reprises sur les réseaux
sociaux on a essayé d'obtenir des photos
de l'intérieur du pays et c'est très
compliqué la moindre photo qui serait
prise peut conduire à la mort de celui
qui l' prend et donc on a décidé de
faire une exposition qui porterait la
voix du peuple iranien d'ici en France
nous avons organisé cette exposition et
cette journée de conférence avec le
modemme qui nous a apporté son soutien
qui nous a montré son engagement c'est
le premier parti politique qui nous
soutient aussi fortement dans notre
démarche le combat des Iraniens
aujourd'hui est un combat d'un courage
absolu ils se battent pour leur liberté
ils se battent pour un Iran démocratique
et c'est par conséquent le devoir de la
communauté internationale et de toutes
les démocraties de porter la voix de
leur combat comme le fait le modem
aujourd'hui